I would like to start with a question, is
it just me or are there other people here in the audience
who are a little
dissatisfied with politicians,
so let's look at the data if we look at
the presidential elections in the
world over the last 30 years, we
wonder what was the participation of
people,
the median in the world was only 67%,
then we went to Europe and we
asked ourselves, well, how many people participate
in the elections for the
European Parliament and we are going to realize that the
median participation in an election
for the European Parliament is  only
42% and then we come here to
new york city and we ask ourselves how many
people voted the last time they had
an election for mayor and that was
last year and only 24
percent of people voted what does
this mean  this means if friends
was still a tv show
just joey and maybe fib and they went to vote
and obviously you can't blame them
because really people are a
little bit tired of politicians and the
way elections happen
recently we've  learned that the
data that people use to
communicate with their friends and
family is also used by
political parties to target
propaganda with surgical precision
but this idea of ​​targeting
propaganda to people for
political purposes is not new today  nowadays
clicks were used before the demographics
of the people or places where they lived were used and
the fact that propaganda
has always been targeted for political purposes is
something that is quite obvious because
democracy has a
basic vulnerability and this is the idea  of a
representative these kings in turns
are basically the Achilles heel of
democracy is the point that if one
wanted to capture the system the point
that one has to attack this is a
weak point and therefore when one tries
to capture a democratic system it is
What one tries to do is capture who
that representative is or capture the
way in which people elect the
representative,
but this is the end of our story, there
are no alternatives
and there are people who have thought of
alternatives
for democratic participation in
this alternative life.  of
direct democracy, he says, look, let's make the kit for the
politicians and let's vote directly
on the bills. The
problem with this idea is that it is very
innocent because the volume of
bills that exists is so
broad that it would overwhelm the capacity
of  Anyone, if we see the
US Congress between 2015 and
2016, the Chamber of Deputies evaluated
more than 6,000 bills, the Senate
has more than 3,000 bills and
more than 300 laws have been approved, what
this means is  for
a direct democracy to be written people
would have to participate as much as
maybe nine times a day and that's a lot
more than any of us
could do so people who
have thought of other alternatives for
example we can have a
liquid democracy to a democracy  fluid this is
the idea that we can give
our voting power to another person who
can give it to another person and we
generate networks of followers
the network of followers eventually
leads to certain people who are the
decision makers
instead of the  followers of them but
this system does not change the
limitation of our
cognitive capacity either and it is also very close to
the idea of ​​having a representative
so what I am going to do today
is I am going to provoke it and I am going to ask another
question I am going to ask myself well  what
if instead of trying to get rid of
politicians
we try to automate
the idea of ​​automation is not a new
game it would be almost 300 years ago when
people in french realized that they
could make a marriage between
looms and steam engines  and at that
moment the autonomous looms began to be developed
and these
autonomous looms began to give an explosion
of creativity now people
did not have to spend time doing
repetitive tasks but instead I am going to
start designing patterns for the
fabrics using punch cards
this creativity  it was huge but it also
gave us other lessons of how
automation happens just as we
went from the handloom to the
autonomous loom we have learned to automate
systems using a text that is quite
similar in the story and the next one
humans first identify a
need in the case  of the loom, the
need is the need for the wardrobe,
then we generate tools that
help us assist in making that need,
in this case it is the loom,
and then we study how people
use these tools to be able to
automate people.
In the case of the loom, it takes us thousands
of  years in learning how people
used a loom to go from a
mechanical loom to an autonomous loom in the case
of the car where the need for
transportation after maybe a little over
100 years we are going from a
mechanical car to an autonomous car but the
difference is  that today
automation is accelerating this is
a video that a friend of mine who works at
toshiba shared with me and this is a
factory that manufactures solid hard drives
in which there is no person in the
factory -between it is a robot
and what I  What I do in my day to day is
to generate tools that help to
integrate, distribute and visualize data on a
large scale at the scale of a country or at the
scale of a company to help
manage a future in which the
workforce will have a
component  Autonomous important, and we are
also going to need autonomy, is the way
in which we have the
executive tasks of these organizations,
but what I am here to talk about
today is not the tools that I have
built with the
executive tasks of countries or
companies in mind.  But legislative tasks
are a little more complex
because we all have differences of
opinion and it is difficult for us to reach an
agreement and we have to be able to
consider the opinions of others,
maintaining a certain civil dialogue
and constructive participation
and in general always  We have believed that
in order to have a better democracy what
we need are more
communication tools and since the invention of the
printing press we have tried to improve
our participation by giving
people access to more communication
but the problem is that this is not a
communication problem  Because what
we really have is a problem
of cognitive bandwidth, if we have
another communication channel, another to another
application, another way of communicating, it
will not be able to process 9
bills a day, then what
we need is another type of technology.
not communication technology, but
augmentation technology
here, for example, we have two people and we
have many communication channels
between them and each time these
communication faces are taking us further,
so what we need is not
to add another channel but to generate
certain avatars or certain assistants
that  help us to take charge of part
of this information that help us with
recommendations that help us make
decisions in such a way that we
can handle a larger volume of
information is not an
automation that replaces us but an
automation that augments us with
artificial intelligence  It is not here to
change us and to replace them, but rather it
is a tool like any other,
like when you pick up a fork to
pick up a strawberry, you can now use
artificial intelligence to help you
make decisions, and this idea
is not new, as is the idea of ​​the loom.
autonomous is not 300 years old the idea of
using software agents to make
decisions in an age that is already
decades old and we use it every day we
ask these software agents
to help us find a route to
travel as it is a place that  help us
choose the songs that we are going to
listen to or recommend books
that we would like to read so now
when we arrive at the 21st century and we see the
technological space where we are,
we realize that there is an idea today
that is as obvious as putting a
steam engine to a loom and this idea
is to combine the idea of
direct democracy with the idea of ​​virtual agents
so imagine a future where
democracy is a little bit different in
which you don't vote for a
representative who represents
you and many  other people plus a
representative that for all this is
practical today is autonomous because
the day after he is elected
you lose control over them
but this representative now
represents only you each one of
you is personalized and the trick is
that since this representative is
personalized we can't have one
person to represent another we would
run out of people what we have to
have in a software agent that is
personalized to represent you
with all that weird combination of
political tastes maybe one person can have
that where perhaps it is
economically conservative but socially liberal and
that in general the package is that you are not
satisfied with those combinations and there is an
idea that I understand that many are
scared of the idea of ​​having
artificial intelligence in the government or
having a  robot from the future being part
of our government
may sound scary but actually
when we had a robot from the future
in the government was he was a nice guy at the
end of the day so what would the
version of this tool look like
so there is a pretty
simple tool a person would enter  a site
would create a user and create an avatar and
the first thing that should be a market of
different tools that would be
available to train this avatar
would answer surveys would connect this
system perhaps their reading habits or
other types of data that they have online
and there would be no exception  there was no
lie because we are not collecting
data to communicate with our
friends and our family and then it is
being used to make
political decisions this data is being
collected to deliver an avatar
then there would be another market where you
choose an algorithm that we are going to use
to predict  and your political tastes or
your decisions on the
bills based on the data that you have
shared and based on the data of the
bills and this is also an
open market because nobody can
own this there are people who can
submit algorithms to us  and the algorithms
can be simple or they can be
complex
is able to see how this algorithm
is making predictions can
correct them and can choose and can
change and with that the system remains
open finally there is a space where
the person can arrive and evaluate see
what is it that the algorithm is
choosing if it agrees or
disagrees and with that it corrects
algorithms and this helps these
different algorithms to learn
obviously there are many questions that
you have how is it that we train
these algorithms since the owner of this
type  of things and what is happening with my
granny she is 80 years old and she does not know how to use the
internet and she is saying that the robots
have to vote
do not worry whenever you have a
new idea be careful that the
pessimists
have a problem for any
solution
in reality this what  It seems
controversial. I am going to show you that it
is not because what we are
doing is not changing the
current system but rather expanding
its design space. So
now imagine the design space for democracy in
the context that each one of you
has an agent.  virtual that can
represent them in an avatar congress
be good imagine that the algorithm that
all these agents have is the same and it
is the following these agents are going to
do exactly what the
politician who was elected to represent
you in your district does in this case  what do
we have the current democracy
exactly the current democracy the
current democracy in fact in a
particular case of this democracy augmented
in a corner solution as one would
say in a technical language but what
one has when thinking about democracy with
this interface  of user
is the ability to be able to move to another
slowly one can be good what if I
don't want to be represented by a politician
but the average of these two flyer and
average of this other
or maybe I can get to a world where
I have a semi fluid democracy  And
eventually I'm going to a world where,
well, instead of taking an average over
reps, maybe what I want is
to have an artificial intelligence algorithm
that tries to learn from me,
looks at the bills and
recommends or helps me make  decisions
and there is this whole continuum to
explore
how we started the revolution and
in revolutions I don't believe much I
believe in evolution more so I
like the idea that this is a continuum
so the revolution will not start
with a protest it will not  to start with
none of the things that we
traditionally use to make revolutions,
the way this is going to start
is perhaps by doing small projects
in universities, in schools, in
newspapers, and that are unofficial
because there is nothing illegal about making an
algorithm that takes  your data and
make a prediction of how you would vote if
you were in the congress of your country
but it helps you to give that factual control
and eventually in these small
projects that perhaps involve a thousand
people in a thousand people hundreds of
people we are going to start  learning how to
train these algorithms how to make
these algorithms transparent how to
make sure the data is stored
securely and little by little little by
little maybe we'll
start to get used to the idea that
the user interface of  democracy
can be better one of the hypotheses that
I have is that we use democracy very
little because the user interface
is very bad
and perhaps we would use it more if we have the
best way to interact with it
so I agree every day
today  day of 2018 sounds crazy
but this crazy thing today maybe
when my daughter is my age it won't
be crazy anymore it will be an idea that
her dad said 30 years ago or more on
stage in vancouver and from  new york and
at that time we may
be at the end of our story but
she will be at the beginning of
hers thank you very much
[Applause]